This is radio lab.
I'm Jad Abumrad and I'm Robert Krulwich and our show today is about deception
than we thought. We're better to start then with snakes.
Oh this is where you keep all your snakes? Well it keeps us home here.
We have a variety of, some of the lizards are working with,
this is Gordon Burkhart. He works at the University of Tennessee,
a paid them visit recently.
And I have several rooms here where we keep a variety of different reptiles and
he's got this one little snake that he likes to show off. Small guy,
but I just have a pencil called the hognose snake. These are the hog,
those Nikes.
So you can see this guy who is already starting to go into the split.
Gordon pops the top off the cage and then does something interesting.
But what I'll do is pink. He puts a chicken puppet,
a puppet of a chicken on his left hand,
and then with this puppet he begins to kind of attack the snake or mock attack,
emulate like peck near it, bird that might be attacking it.
What happens next is kind of shocking and you can see now how was hiding his
hand a little bit. It's coiling,
it fail first the snake flips over on its back there it goes upside down.
Then it vomits. Blood blood will even come out of the mouth.
Then it poos itself and as he knows he's starting to deprecate a little bit.
It's writhing and then it gets really it.
It'll finally stop still.
In fact, we'll stop breathing. It's all bluff.
All a show. It was like, wait, that is that. It's not bluffing and touching.
Sure, but as soon as we took a few steps back from the cage, the snake pops,
it set up, goes on,
flattens itself now close and there it was alive again and then it'll start to
breathe
and gays around. It was lying basically. That's pretty good.
Thank you very much. Hello. You know,
as the world turns was kind of an ordinary lie really. It was. Sure.
When was the last time you pooed yourself for a lot? Wow.
I could lie to you so beautifully. You would be on your back. Tongue out.
No Way. Because I would catch you back. No, you wouldn't get it. Yeah.
Would though. You would not. I would totally catch him.
So sorry to tell you this. That's my catch. Nope. If it were me,
no you wouldn't. So that's our,
our know people who lie and the people who catch them, that
all [inaudible]
to get things started in earnest.
Let us go to every New Yorker's favorite spot.
John F. Kennedy Airport. Of course.
It's a little place I like to go to get away from it all.
I ended up there with our producer Ellen, a foreign,
we hadn't actually met to come.
It's a guy that we had been interviewing in order for a lar to be portrayed by
demeanor. This is amber has to be, or high emotional.
Right in the middle of the interview, he had gotten a call. Hello? Hello.
Said he had to run. And we're like, crap, we have more questions.
What are we gonna do? So we decided to jump in the car with him year.
We were the relaxing presence of men with big guns.
Yes.
There's these guys that look like they're in combat uniform for Iraq and they
have automatic weapon in case this is Paul Ekman, Ekman, e k m. A. S. A.
A security expert, right? Yes. What he would be called nowadays,
and speaking of security,
the reason he's here today at JFK Airport is to talk with jet blue security,
teach them a few things about how they might do their jobs better. Okay.
We have it, but they'll report it in a building that's out in a restaurant,
not a jump rope. Primary security kicks us out.
We are leaving their terminal and the only place it seems we're allowed to stand
about right here as on the concrete medium between two lanes of traffic where
Eckman finally pulls out the thing.
He'd been hoping to show the folks at jet blue. Yeah.
See here we have your [inaudible], your very stylish little laptop. Yeah,
just starting up.
It's a simple computer program that he promises about 40 minutes.
We'll teach you to peer into a person's soul.
[inaudible] click start. All right, click on the start button. Okay.
I'm stepping forward to the computer here. It's loading images.
Please wave about waiting for the pitch. Okay,
so I ain't gonna see that one again. That was so fast.
Whoa. What his that I'll promise I'll tell you, but let me just keep going.
This all right. Okay.
Blaine. Paul Ekman. Studies faces the human face.
He's probably studied the face more than anyone
up until my work that was published in 78 we didn't really know how many
expressions that face could make and there was nothing like of musical notation
for the face,
so about 30 years ago he began by examining his own face very closely to see how
many muscles are in there.
There are roughly 50 then he spent the next couple of decades trying to figure
out how many ways those muscles can combine to form a facial expression.
I developed something called the facial action coding system.
Basically a muscular scoring system that you can apply to photographs, film,
or real life behavior. You just did a a one two for grading.
You're numbering my facial expression. The one,
two is the most common thing in the world.
Just raising your eyebrows up is one to five.
It's just raising the upper eyelid. Seven is ten second or lower.
All in all the human faces capable of 3000 different expressions.
That's what he thinks and as we sat in his publisher's office in Midtown
Manhattan, this is about an hour before the airport incident, right? An example.
Yeah. He demonstrated a few. Yeah.
Okay. If you fabricate anger,
it's very unlikely you'll put in what we call the anchor reliable muscle,
which most people can't. Rolland early move and get a reliable,
that's what it is. Yeah. I want to see where it is
you're seeing you touching the red margin of my lips.
Well, you just look, you look fierce when you do that instantly.
So if you want know someone's mad, look at their lips. Conversely,
if you want another happy, like genuinely happy and they're not just faking it,
he says, look at their eyelids.
The skin in between your eyebrows and your upper eyelid and the genuine
spontaneous enjoyment smile that's skin moves slightly down,
hard to detect, but visible. If you know
you just did it when you said that. Anyways.
The reason that we are talking about him here an hour on lying is because with
all the attention that's being paid these days to finding lies by using fancy
brain scanners Heckman is kind of on a crusade terminus that you don't have to
do that.
You don't have to look in the brain because the brain is actually directly
connected to the face in ways that we can't.
All of these muscles are activated in voluntarily.
When an emotion occurs without your choice.
Are there things happening on my face, on her face,
on any face that you're only here we don't even know and I'll see about my tried
the naked face,
which brings me to my new favorite word. Leakage. Leakage.
Leakage. Yes,
it is a word you will hear again and again when you talk to anyone in the field
of like hatching. Take for example, Barry McManus, Barry El McManus,
mcma and u s he's a long time CIA interrogator.
Physiological leakage could be anywhere from sweat gland activity.
When someone knows that they're misleading you and they break out in a sweat,
that's because of the autonomic nervous system that you have no control over.
Basically telling the truth as easy. That is the crux of it.
According to Steve Silverman, a reporter for wired magazine,
the truth is kind of sitting there in your brain. Your brain knows it.
You say it, no problem,
but your brain has to work harder to generate the light.
There is an effort and with that there's always leakage even in an instantaneous
moment.
Sometimes you even hear it where a person's reading pattern will change or the
size that people do at what particular time did they do it?
If you're not trained to look at it, most people ignore it,
but if you've been trained and you know what to look for according to Barry
McManus, it will strike you right in the face. Speaking of faces,
usually talking about a particular brand of facial leakage that Paul Ekman
specializes in has to do with something that he calls [inaudible]
micro facial expression are very fast facial expression about 25th of a second.
Okay. Just to just as an example, let's just let us imagine, Robert,
that you're smiling.
Okay.
Okay. Yeah, but on the inside, as those of us who know, you can attest,
maybe you've got some rage, a little, a little bit, yeah, just a little bit,
but on the outside you're smiling.
Now a micro expression is when for the tiniest, tiniest moment,
a little bit of that inner rage slips out onto your face.
[inaudible]
and these are just little like just fleeting expressions on.
They're usually pretty extreme, but they're very fast. It happens constantly,
says so fast that most of us don't see it at all. Most of us don't. When
I say most of them, he never had 95% of us in this though.
But once you learn that you don't miss that. Once you, according to Ackman,
you wake up to the startling possibility that ties are everywhere.
It's enough to make a man obsessed.
When my daughter was born during seven years ago,
I decided that I would take on as a life test to see whether I could leave
a line for that line to see whether you could lead your life without line. Yeah,
that sounds possible. It's very tough,
but I'm always looking to see whether there's a way I can solve a problem.
It makes it more interesting than just telling a lie is really dumb.
But you could argue that telling a lie is it's just what we do. No,
we don't just do that.
Most of the time we lie out of laziness or timidity.
I got put in a terrible situation by a friend who had invited me to a dinner
party and the company was doll and the food was worse.
I sure didn't want to go again.
So he invites me again about two months later and I say, I'm sorry.
I can't make it. I'm being polite. Not sure I could have made it. And he said,
oh, well, we enjoyed having you so much. Tell me a date when you could make it.
How am I going to get out of that? I'm prepared,
I'm prepared.
So I said to him with the truth of the matter is that at this point in my life,
I'm very busy and her friends I've had for decades that I don't get enough time
to see and I really can't pursue new friendships,
but that sort of shows it takes a lot of work not to lie and for life or what
that is. This one you feel like a zen hero guide. Again,
I can stay truthful. I didn't take the easy path.
When Paul Ekman began to walk the path of the honest man,
he was faced with a question that has plagued other honest men for centuries,
which is what exactly is a lie?
Like how do you define it exactly like,
I mean there are different kinds clearly and some are definitely more okay than
others. Where do you draw the line? Eventually he settled on two criteria.
A lie is a deliberate choice,
a deliberate choice to mislead a target without any notification.
So according to that definition, an actor is not a lawyer,
although a good actor.
I saw a good actor last night in a play and I was for time misled.
Or even that I even had tears because he had misled me,
but I was notified. So twos are canceled.
My a deception in a similar way, bluffing at poker,
it's not lying because bluffing is in the rules.
It's understood that's part of the game. So therefore you are notified.
It depends. Maybe the rules of, with my wife, we're during our 28th year,
my wife taught me
that what I'm supposed to say when she comes in with a new dress,
I'm not supposed to say, Gee,
that's not a flattering cut or the color is wrong or that's for someone 20 years
younger, all of which might be true. [inaudible] I'm supposed to say smashing.
So, okay.
I've agreed to those rules and their rules I've agreed to is that I will not
tell her the truth. And since we've agreed about that, I'm not lying.
So is this like the poker game where you're allowed to bluff? I'm required to.
You're giving yourself a loophole though. Oh No. No. Cause she's notified.
She knows she can't count on that. That sounds like very lawyerly to me.
Just then his phone rings.
Mom, mom. Hello.
Hello? Hello. Oh, that's my ride.
We're gonna ride out to JFK with me. Yeah, absolutely.
You know this goes, we pile in the car, go to the airport, get kicked out.
Tell reporter in a building to there.
We were on the medium center strip at JFK coldish winter day and Paul Ekman
finally pulled the thing out of his bag.
It's new technology that he thinks is going to help our chances at catching
liars at the airport. Basically it is a computer game. It's loading images.
Please wait. You are shown a face on a screen.
The faces fixed in an expression like a smile at say and then waiting for the
pinch at k. Pow.
Another different expression flashes for a moment. Whoa. That was so fast.
So fast. And then on the screen you're asked, what was that micro expression?
Oh, was it a surprise? You got it right.
Let's try another. Are you ready? Okay.
I need to see that one again. Angry, angry, angry. All right,
let's go and try it. Anger. Right.
Wow. It started out pretty strong. Okay, here we go. All right,
you're going to get three in a row,
then it was all downhill. Oh,
I didn't even begin to catch that contempt
in the end. After several minutes of this try again.
I ended up getting more wrong than right.
Which put my micro expression identifying powers. Oh No. Less you.
One more time. Chance I could have flipped a coin and I would have done better,
but, but what if you were good at it?
What if you were able to identify the particular expressions?
What would you know? Well, I wouldn't, I would know.
I guess all I really know is that they were concealing something. Some emotion.
That's, yeah, and that's it. Yeah. And in fact on the way over in the car,
Ekman said a point blank. If you are looking for some sure. Fire dead giveaway.
Sign of lying.
It's just not there because we don't have, we don't have a Pinocchio's nurse.
Sure.
Oh,
we don't have something that only occurs when people are lying. Really?
So there is not say a muscle number,
a 19 that if it twitches in a certain way is a bulletproof hallmark of lying
that doesn't exist. That's pretty easy as nerves.
Is there something close to it on our faces? No.
There are signs of unusual cognitive load or emotional nun,
and that can occur for a lot of reasons and you've got to find out the reasons,
so you're never going to be able to have an idiot behind the machine.
In other words, nope.
Radio level returning them.